let's turn back the TV clock even
further of course while we were all
about Zack and Kelly on Saved by the
Bell
mark-paul Gosselaar was actually dating
another one of his co-stars
[Music]
mark-paul was just 15 and elizabeth
berkley was 17 when the iconic show
started he just revealed that there was
some after-school activity going on
between them we dated you want to call
it dating you're in an environment you
know how it is when you're working on a
set and we were young
mark-paul sat down with Otto Faris on
her podcast unqualified where he says he
dated his co-star because well it was
the thing to do you're in LA so right
you're in your cars
and you come to set and you do your work
and you're with these beautiful women
and you're not going to school so you
don't have a lot of choices today
elizabeth is 46 and is married to
designer Greg Lauren the nephew of
fashion icon Ralph Lauren Mark Paul is
44 and the father of four kids Elizabeth
went on to star in the very grown-up
movie showgirls and we uncovered this
lost et footage sexy sexy sexy on the
set of the movie Saved by the Bell
wedding in Las Vegas Marc Paul was the
one dressed like a Vegas showgirl she's
definitely affiliated I'm like on the
phone over there calling my girlfriend
people are taking pictures and I didn't
notice but my I was like this
[Music]